[Música]
en afganistán las defensas antimisiles
de eeuu se interceptaron al menos cinco
cohetes que fueron disparados al
aeropuerto de kabul desde un vehículo
aún sin confirmar víctimas o el origen
del ataque para tan poco más de 24 horas
para la retirada total de las tropas
extranjeras tras las evacuaciones de
masivas de las últimas dos semanas
turquía y grecia refuerzan sus fronteras
ante el éxodo de afganos que viajan
diariamente pasando por iran para buscar
puerto seguro en europa previamente
acnur anunció que al menos un medio
millón de locales podrían huir de su
país para finales de este año tenemos
análisis
y el huracán a aída uno de los más
poderosos en tocar tierra en eeuu se ha
degradado a tormenta tropical esta
madrugada así lo confirmó el centro
nacional de huracanes tras el paso del
fenómeno por nueva orleans dejando más
de un millón de hogares sin electricidad
y una persona fallecida
regresamos con ustedes para actualizar
la información internacional en france
24 iniciamos en afganistán porque las
defensas antimisiles de eeuu se
interceptaron unos 5 cohetes que fueron
disparados al aeropuerto de kabul esto a
pocas horas de que finalice el plazo
para la retirada total de las tropas
extranjeras del país se desconoce el
origen del ataque washington ha evacuado
a unas 114 mil 400 personas desde el 14
de agosto un día antes de la toma de
kabul por el talibán que ahora domina el
país el enfoque de evacuación de civiles
cambio por la urgencia de sacar a las
tropas
remanentes en kabul después del ataque
suicida con bomba del estado islámico
que dejó al menos 170 fallecidos afuera
del aeropuerto
entretanto este lunes francia reino
unido y alemania- presentan ante el
consejo de seguridad de naciones unidas
la propuesta de una zona segura para
continuar con las evacuaciones de
nacionales más allá de este 31 de agosto
ya solo un día de la fecha prevista para
la retirada definitiva de las tropas
internacionales de afganistán las
evacuaciones de extranjeros y nacionales
afganos van llegando a su fin sin
embargo son muchos los afganos que
permanecen en el país susceptibles de
ser perseguidos por los talibanes y sin
posibilidades de salir el enviado
especial de france 24 afganistán es
decir el país nos lleva a conocer
algunos de estos hombres que trabajaron
para el ejército francés sobre terreno y
que ahora sienten el abandono de quienes
un día ayudaron reporte desde kabul
un día antes de la retirada definitiva
de las fuerzas extranjeras las
evacuaciones de los refugiados afganos
se dan por terminadas sin embargo
cuántos son los que se quedaron atrás en
un afganistán de futuro incierto
podrían ser objetivos prioritarios para
los talibanes que ya los buscan porque
ayudaron a extranjeros y eso es una
línea roja para los talibanes
con la ayuda de una red clandestina
vamos a encontrarnos con algunos ex
colaboradores del ejército francés en un
lugar secreto de la capital todos estos
hombres en un momento u otro sirvieron a
francia durante su intervención en
afganistán
recibí este email en el que está escrito
que debo estar preparado para irme con
mi familia rápidamente que la embajada
me iba a llamar y que debo preparar mi
equipaje en seguida vendí todo lo que
teníamos ahora no tenemos nada
fuimos al aeropuerto pero no logramos
cruzar las puertas antes de ir hice
todos los papeles y los envié siguiendo
el procedimiento indicado por el
ministerio de y de asuntos extranjeros
pero la embajada dice que tenemos que
esperar
no podemos salir de nuestra patria
porque los talibanes registran todos los
teléfonos y miran todos los detalles
la situación es mínima la nuestra vida
está en peligro y hemos trabajado para
el ejército francés al servicio del
pueblo francés en afganistán ahora
pedimos que todos seamos evacuados del
país recurso concluyó busti post pedimos
al ejército francés que se acuerde de
que un día fuimos nosotros quienes
ayudamos a sus soldados quienes les
acompañamos en sus misiones ahora son
ellos quienes deben ayudarnos no podemos
ir a ninguna parte formó un gobierno y
bolton a neuer estos hombres y sus
familias todavía están aturdidos un día
quizás su sentimiento cambiará pero por
ahora sienten que francia los ha
traicionado
cerca de mil afganos viajan diariamente
hacia iran huyendo del régimen talibán
su objetivo es atravesar el país vecino
hasta llegar a europa pero países como
turquía y grecia empiezan a reforzar sus
fronteras con el objetivo de evitar una
crisis migratoria pues acnur anunció que
al menos un medio millón de afganos
podrían huir de su país para finales de
este año
quienes no logran salir por vía aérea lo
intentan en las fronteras terrestres el
objetivo es el mismo huir de afganistán
tras la toma del poder por parte del
grupo talibán diariamente cientos de
afganos cruzan la zona limítrofe con el
vecino irán
tenemos entre 700.000 viajeros que
entran cada día modernizada y en cuanto
a las precauciones que se toman en la
frontera con respecto al coronavirus
tomamos muestras no innovas en el mundo
de pactarse probamos las temperaturas y
hacemos simetrías de pulso a los
entrantes millán al youm y sed lex o sea
en uno de los pocos pasos fronterizos
entre ambos países ubicado entre más at
ciudad de irán e irak la ciudad
occidental de afganistán y es que según
el alto comisionado de las naciones
unidas para los refugiados para finales
del año cerca de medio millón de afganos
podría huir de su país
de ory o la situación generada es
turbulenta a la gente le preocupa que
pueda estallar de nuevo una guerra civil
estéreo verse que los talibanes todavía
no controlan una de las provincias de
afganistán no te deja vivo ya que la
mayoría de los políticos y han ido de
afganistán te equivocas y beauséjour y
si vos
muchos de los migrantes viajan a través
de iran para llegar hasta turquía con
miras a seguir su camino hacia europa
las autoridades turcas han reforzado su
propia frontera con irán y han expresado
preocupación de que se repita una crisis
de refugiados como la vivida en 2015
como turquía hemos cumplido
suficientemente con nuestras
responsabilidades morales y humanitarias
en materia de inmigración turquía no
puede asumir una nueva carga de
refugiados turquía que alberga
actualmente a 3.7 millones de refugiados
sirios advierte que los países de la
región así como naciones europeas
podrían verse afectadas por los nuevos
flujos migratorios desde afganistán
grecia también ha ampliado su valla
fronteriza con turquía
filippo grandi jefe de refugiados de la
onu dijo que al terminar la evacuación
de kabul una crisis 'a más grande está
comenzando en afganistán para el
análisis nos acompaña desde madrid
españa maría jesús vega portavoz de
acnur en esa nación gracias a ustedes
por estar en france 24 y son 3,5
millones de personas que ya han sido
desplazadas por la violencia dentro del
país más de medio millón desde
principios de este año qué pasará con
ellos ahora que cesaron los
enfrentamientos y que el talibán domina
el país podrán volver a sus casas todos
ellos dependen de programas humanitarios
que no dan abasto
así es la situación de la gente que está
adentro del país desplazada una y otra
vez es uno de los focos de preocupación
en este mundo también para nosotros
seguimos llevando ayuda humanitaria de
urgencia de ese medio millón nuevos
desplazados en 2021 el 80% son además
mujeres y niñas y seguimos viendo una
alta población en situación de riesgo
que son todas aquellas personas que han
estado trabajando con equipos
extranjeros con organizaciones
internacionales con organismos de
defensa militares etcétera y bueno pues
en este momento están realmente en una
situación escondidos bueno pues con alto
alto riesgo para su vida es muy
importante que no nos olvidemos de estas
personas que están dentro del país y
para ellos en concreto es para los que
estamos en este momento bueno pues
poniendo todo nuestro
nuestros objetivos y nuestro interés
junto con el equipo de naciones unidas y
para quienes ya están huyendo del país
puede la comunidad internacional
garantizar que se respete el derecho a
buscar protección internacional en
países como los europeos por ejemplo la
mayoría de refugiados buscan además
ayuda en pakistán y en irán cómo se
pueden repartir las cargas con otras
naciones
bueno efectivamente estás dando en el
clavo aparte de estas personas que están
siendo evacuadas que son una mínima
parte de la gente que necesita
protección lo que hemos hecho un
llamamiento desde acnur es para que se
dejen las fronteras abiertas
pakistán y dan y acogen al 90% de la
población refugiada afgana que son
26 millones de personas en todo el mundo
y aunque el flujo de personas que están
saliendo del país es pequeño todavía no
estamos viendo grandes cifras es cierto
que en este momento es muy difícil
atravesar fronteras pedimos por favor a
todos los países que echen una mano que
compartan esta responsabilidad de
proteger estos países han hecho a lo
largo de muchas décadas cuatro décadas
de conflictos en afganistán y de salidas
mucho por acoger dentro de su territorio
y dar bueno pues cobijo y protección a
estas personas pero pedimos también esto
a todos los países y desde luego las
fronteras europeas
no son una excepción en cuanto a que se
abra a la posibilidad de pedir asilo a
refugiados afganos a personas que están
en este momento en necesidad de
protección internacional pese a las
dificultades que hay para atravesar como
digo fronteras internacionales maría
jesús cuáles son las soluciones a largo
plazo es realista por ejemplo la idea
que se está planteando de una zona
segura de la onu en afganistán
bueno va a haber que hacer distintos
escenarios el escenario de trabajo
dentro del país nosotros lo estamos
barajando al mismo tiempo estamos en
preparación con planes de contingencia
en los países limítrofes pakistán e irán
que ha sido los tradicionalmente
acogedores de refugiados ahí hay que
trabajar también para que estos países
no continúen siendo los que más presión
acogen y si los tienen que por lo menos
tengan recursos económicos para poder
responder al mismo tiempo los programas
de reasentamiento que son esas esos
traslados desde primeros países de asilo
de refugiados que se encuentran en
situación complicada vulnerable
incluyendo pues mujeres niños o personas
con dolencias o con problemas médicos
hacia países seguros esos programas
también necesitan un refuerzo del año
pasado por ejemplo pues del millón
cuatrocientos mil refugiados que
teníamos identificados desde acnur como
en necesidad de reasentamiento solamente
llegaron a países seguros 32 mil así que
hay que trabajar en todos los frentes y
ahí seguimos trabajando nosotros con los
equipos en el país y seguiremos mientras
bueno pues el acceso esta población y
las condiciones de seguridad nos lo
permitan a pesar de toda esta situación
tan tan durísima que se está viviendo
maría jesús vega representante de acnur
en españa gracias a usted por estar con
nosotros y cambiamos de tema en eeuu a
ellas se degradó a tormenta tropical el
fenómeno que hasta hace pocas horas fue
uno de los huracanes más fuertes que ha
azotado eeuu derivó en cortes de
electricidad en la ciudad de nueva
orleans en luisiana
alrededor de un millón de personas están
sin servicios y las autoridades dicen
que los daños podrían agudizarse
con vientos de hasta 240 kilómetros por
hora ayuda dejó a su paso destrucción
tumbando árboles dañando edificios como
este hospital
ayuda dejó sin electricidad a toda nueva
orleans y otras áreas en luisiana y
misisipí dejando a más de un millón de
residentes en la oscuridad
desplegaremos nuestras fuerzas para
evitar que ocurran robos y garantizar la
seguridad de los ciudadanos y sus
propiedades algunos residentes trataron
de blindar sus hogares con la esperanza
de permanecer sanos y salvos adentro
otros abandonaron áreas en riesgo
buscando refugio la devastación mortal
causada por el huracán katrina
exactamente hace 16 años estuvo presente
en la memoria de todos solo queremos
irnos rápido para poner a los niños a
salvo el pronóstico indicaba que ayuda
se debilitaría rápidamente fuertes
lluvias han elevado los niveles de agua
en alabama con equipos de rescate listos
para tomar acción apenas las condiciones
climáticas les permitan despegar
las autoridades dicen que han hecho todo
lo que pueden hacer para evitar una
tragedia del nivel de katrina y evitar
repetir la misma historia se han
invertido miles de millones de dólares
más de 14 mil millones en nuestro
sistema de protección de diques tenemos
más tecnología y ciencia sobre estos
avances
las autoridades están monitoreando los
centros de salud en el estado miles de
pacientes por kobe 19 100 hospitalizados
y muchos no pudieron ser evacuados ya
que no hay un lugar seguro para
enviarlos
y en méxico el fenómeno no ahora ahora
con categoría de tormenta tropical dejó
un niño fallecido en la ciudad turística
de puerto vallarta después de que
lluvias torrenciales y fuertes vientos
causaron el colapso parcial de un
edificio también en puerto vallarta se
desbordó un río un puente quedó
destruido y las vías inundadas el centro
nacional de huracanes dijo que no ahora
podría producir lluvias intensas a lo
largo de la costa oeste de méxico desde
jalisco hasta sonora hasta el fin de
semana también podría producir
inundaciones repentinas y deslizamientos
son al menos 11 los fallecidos en la
amazonía peruana y hay casi una decena
de desaparecidos por el impacto entre
dos embarcaciones fluviales en el río
huallaga en la región de loreto seis
personas están heridas entre al menos 60
que lograron ser rescatadas con el apoyo
de la marina del país aún se realizan
labores de rescate buscando a
sobrevivientes y recuperando cuerpos
grandes
y los que podemos
la ampliación de esta y otras noticias
usted los puede encontrar en nuestro
sitio web france24 puntocom ya
regresamos con más siga con nosotros y
feliz mañana
[Música]